[Musik]
hey was geht weil das und sein name ist
luca und ich befinde mich hier heute mal
wieder nicht alleine sondern mit jude
law
das ist das julab druck auf jeden fall
hatte ich die glorreiche idee das ist
jude einfach mal in einen ein euro laden
nebenan gehen könnte und sich doch
einfach mal alle produkte die ist da
gibt kaufen gab den offiziellen auf
jeden fall geht jetzt von mir 20 euro
bekommen und mit diesen 20 euro
irgendwelche artikel im ein euro
geschäft kaufen gehen und dann werdet
ihr mich hier wiedersehen in meiner
wohnung wie ich das auspacken aber jetzt
erstmal juli wie sie das einkaufen geht
[Musik]
mir wurde gesagt dass ich hier nicht
ja ich mache einfach trotzdem würde ich
gedacht dass es hier mehr sachen gibt
aber ich finde ich nicht so viel
[Applaus]
ich mache also summa summarum look
zeigen niemand weiß nicht was passiert
dass ich das nicht mache aber hier sind
viele leute gemacht
[Musik]
ich kaufe luftschlag nur dass die frau
nicht auch ein mindest spielen weil
lukas ich mag also ich bin jetzt fertig
und ich habe 22 eur 25 zeit also ein
bisschen zu viel ich dir jetzt auf jeden
fall wieder fröhlich hoffe ich hab nicht
komplette scheiße gekauft ich konnte
alle leute an weil plötzlich bin aber
egal jurist mit den sachen wieder
angekommen
ich packte jetzt aus
hatte bei der kamera das auch
alterklasse hört ja auch das
meeresrauschen also meine damen und
herren juni wieder angekommen außerdem
einen euro geschätzt ich bin froh dass
du es überlebt hast juli ich habe die
datei noch nicht gesehen wie sie darum
gelaufen ist oder was sie hier gekauft
hat das heißt ich werde jetzt einfach
mal in die hand nehmen hier eingreifen
und das erste produkt lassen sie mir
mitgebracht hatte
ich kaufte mir keinen scheiß nein danke
mich und wir machen heute mit dem
nächsten produkte in denen meine damen
und herren das nächste was mich wieder
mitgebracht hat ist ein bass das soll
ich mir hier mit in die haare klemmen ja
hast du bist der held dass ich toll
der hält die amerikaner die bälle im tor
fällt formal ist jetzt gmbh von mir das
auf jeden fall an der stelle schon mal
danke jurist wird das hundefutter nicht
existenten rund um den wutbürger nicht
existenten schwäbisches produkt meine
damen und herren haben wir das ist kein
ding was soll das denn sein ließ münster
dran steht
[Musik]
ich habe ein fahrrad
also wenn ich den leser durch die
innenstadt laufe und mir dass es so voll
ist kann ich einfach weiter ausbauen ich
dachte halt wirklich zuerst ist das
irgendwie so ein lolli wer oder so die
unbedingt an den tieren so schlecht aber
[Musik]
den kann man auch gut so ist halt die
fresse benutzen bei dieses produkt meine
damen würd ich sagen wir mal das ganze
hätte was hier drin liegt tatsächlich
kein euro gekostet oder ich werde auch
nicht was es ist nicht zu erwarten dass
der titel hat ein euro ja kann ich muss
dafür dass er zweimal 1 euro gekostet
dann weiß ich noch nicht genau was es
ist aber jetzt steht achtung nicht für
kinder unter drei jahren
[Musik]
wer möchte dem büchertisch aufgebaut das
herzliche jetzt immer die kugel hin und
ich schwöre wenn ich das ding hoch
nehmen wollen ihn alle richtungen also
für zwei euro geht das echt mega klar
wird spieler hier ein bisschen bieder
freunde netzwerk
nur die wahrheit überhaupt will ja
freunde wenn jemand eine mini bilder
scheinen doch meinen kanal sehen wollt
dann schreibt man die kommentare dass
man dankbar weil hiermit kann man das
jetzt auf jeden fall mal am ball
zunächst es greife ich jetzt wieder
einfach mal die tüte so wie bei jedem
produkt und will als nicht dass es
letzte partie
[Applaus]
aber das gute daran ist wenn man 1
kaputt macht beim ausschneiden hat man
immer noch zwei weitere und zwar mache
jetzt einfach die stinken so krass nach
china das soll ein teil des ist dass man
sich mit denen auch einfach selbst
einspielen kann nämlich wir greifen
wieder die tüte rein meine damen und
herren das heißt jetzt nächstes produkt
haben wir hier von jule gekauft bekommen
ein mega du willst mich auch echt zum
affen machen alter sich beschissen aus
in der tat als nächstes produkt haben
wir hier nach da willst du mich komplett
war
ja ich hab so spart ihr diese brille
würde ich sagen kann julian kommr
aufsetzen
wir machen natürlich direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten produkte was wir hier
vorfinden werden zwei ist ein echt party
machen 2000 jahre später
ich muss sagen das reicht auch war also
freunde wir befinden uns gerade bei mir
auf dem balkon heim und ich werde jetzt
was aber um einfach mal dagegen
schmelzen juli bereits freunde seid ihr
bereit ok könne nicht mit mir reden aber
gut ich wäre für nun die wasserbombe das
war sonderlich unspektakulär eigentlich
aber freunde wir machen ja quasi mit dem
nächsten produkte und zwar haben wir
eine kinder cola ohne koffein erwarte
party jude
das schmeckt wie dieses cola wasser als
geschmolzen
wenn es nicht gut
das nächste produkt aus dem ein euro
geschäft kommt sofort und zwar ist es
das ist ein teleskop spiegel wenn ihr
mich sehen julia alter megageil also
dieses teleskop spiele habe ich auch
keine ahnung wofür ich den mal hin man
gebrauchen kann wahrscheinlich wenn
ihnen gästen zuletzt um die ecke gucken
wir als nächstes ist luke schon aus
party servierten jule die party kann ja
gar nicht mehr gestoppt werden was hast
du dir dabei gedachten sie ganz sachen
hier zu holen es kein recht ihr
irgendwas zu sagen so wie das hier aus
sie hätten die burg auf eine party
spielen billard und unser hund kommt
auch und der hat etwas zu fressen damit
der ruhige haben wir servierten weil wir
da noch kommt
aber wir machen weiter und zwar das
nächste produkt ist ist an dieses willst
du dich komplett verarscht und das ist
papier verfasst und euro ausgegeben das
heißt jetzt nicht gemacht
das ist ein schönes geschenk hab' ja
nicht dass auf jeden fall auch super
toll und dann haben wir als nichts doch
eine
ich weiß dass das ein schweißband ist
jule halb deutschland lebt er mal hier
meine damen und herren wir kommen nun
zum letzten produkt was ich hier fühlen
kann und zwar ist es außerdem ein euro
geschäft als jude getaufte hat ohne dass
ich davon wusste und zwar was ist das
kaugummi jungen firma kaugummi ziehen
wenn ich das jetzt esse wenig lästig und
familien essen muss so wolf
ja meine damen und herren an der stelle
bin ich dann das heutige video fänden
ich hoffe ihr herz auf genau so eine
coole party wie dich heute ist hat euch
genauso viel spaß macht wie mir bei mir
hat schuld rapid ich das nicht ganz los
mit dem abschneiden
daran kann er stelle sich das video dann
allerdings auch bei ich habe noch sehr
gut aufnehmen ketzer seiner kate auf
hass und das wahrscheinlich so häufig
leute kennt ihr das wenn man so eine
kälte lange zeit auf hatte dann sitzt
man die uplink wenn man hat immer noch
nicht dass eventuell noch mal machen
sollen und sie war mal andere produkte
kauft er das gerne mal ein leichter und
sonst dieses komitee ist echt schlecht
gerade zum us-markt aber im endeffekt
nehmen